[Music]
britain's queen elizabeth with the
leaders of the g7 nations during this
week's summit in cornwall
england there president biden was seated
to her left and was a few steps ahead of
the queen as the dignitaries
walked to the stage tomorrow the
president and first lady will share
afternoon tea with the queen at windsor
castle but while that gathering will be
a first for the first couple
the queen's encounters with american
presidents and their wives
is a piece of history all its own
today marks the official celebration of
the queen's 95th birthday
and she's about to mark 70 years on the
throne
but there's another remarkable number
she can boast about
in her long reign the queen may well
have met
more u.s presidents than anyone else
alive today
some were a bit out of order she met the
nation's 31st
president herbert hoover at a 1957
luncheon
24 years after he left office she was
only princess
elizabeth when she and her late husband
met president harry truman in washington
on behalf of her father king george but
most of the encounters have been
as queen and with the sitting president
including
a 1959 visit by dwight eisenhower
to balmoral castle in scotland a 1961
state dinner at buckingham palace for
john and jackie kennedy
and a 1969 palace tour for president
richard nixon
1976 president ford played host
waltzing with queen elizabeth at the
white house to celebrate the nation's
bicentennial
jimmy carter also made quite an
impression on the queen
and her mother during a 1977 buckingham
palace state dinner
instead of bowing his head or shaking
the queen mother's hand
he decided to kiss her right on the lips
ronald reagan a personal favorite of her
majesty
and nice to see you again bonded with
the queen over their mutual
love of horses and in 1991
president george h.w bush took the royal
couple to one of america's favorite
pastimes
a baseball game between the baltimore
orioles
and the oakland a's bill clinton and
george w
bush each met with the queen and prince
philip on numerous occasions without any
major breaches of royal protocol
unfortunately more recent presidents
weren't so lucky
to her majesty the queen
the vitality of the special relationship
between our peoples while toasting the
monarch at a 2009 state dinner
president obama kept right on talking as
the band
played the british national anthem and
most recently
donald trump drew some raised british
eyebrows when he walked ahead of the
queen
during their 2018 visit only time will
tell if the biden's encounter will have
any
awkward moments or be as smooth as a cup
of
earl grey tea i think the queen was
trying to get around
president trump at the time i do believe
that's what it's quite a few people
had attempted to do i mean it's amazing
the amount you have to cover in a piece
like that yeah
how many presidents she's met that's
amazing though
what longevity she looks good she does
she does